let me draw a good old pv diagram that's
my pressure axis this is my volume axis
just like that i have pressure
and volume i showed several videos ago
that if we start at some state here in
the pv diagram right there and then i
change the pressure and a volume to get
to another state and i do it in a
quasi-static way so essentially i'm
always close to equilibrium so my state
variables are always defined i could
have some path that takes me to some
other state right there
and this is my path
i'm going from the state to that state
and we say we say well if i we show that
if i just did this the work done by the
system is the area under this curve and
then if i were to move back to the
previous state
and then if i you know by some path just
some random path that i happen to be
drawing
the work done to the system would be the
area under this light blue curve so the
net work done by the system ended up
being the area inside of this path
so this is let me do it in a different
color
the net work done would be the area
inside of this path
when i go in this clockwise type of
direction so this is
the work
the network let me write network
done by system
done by
the system and now we also know
so let me so that's well we also know
that if we're at some point on this pv
diagram that our state is the same as it
was before so if we go all the way here
and then go all the way back all of our
state variables will not have changed
our pressure is the same as it was
before our volume was the same as it was
before because we went all the way back
to that same point on the pv diagram and
our internal energy is also the same
point as it was before so our change in
internal energy over this path you're
gonna have a different internal energy
here than you had here when you go
around the circle and you get back your
change in internal energy is equal to
zero
and we know that our change in internal
energy
we know that change in internal energy
it's defined as and this is from the
first law of thermodynamics the heat
added to the system
so it's the heat added to the system
minus the work done by the system
now if we go on a closed loop on our pv
diagram then what's our change in
internal energy it's zero
so we get zero
zero change in internal energy because
we're at the same state is equal to
the
heat applied to the system minus the
work done
or and i've done this little little
exercise multiple times i think this is
probably the fourth or fifth time i'm
doing it we get that the heat added to
the system if we just add w to both
sides is equal to the work done by the
system so this area under this
between inside of this path i already
said it's the work done by the system
and if you don't remember even where
that came from it was remember pressure
times volume times change in volume is a
little incremental change in work and
that's why it relates to the area but
we've done that multiple times i won't
go there just yet but so if you have any
area here some heat was added to the
system some net heat
right some some heat was added here and
some heat was probably taken out here
but you have some net heat that's added
to the system and i use that argument to
say why heat wasn't a good um
isn't a good state variable because and
i had a whole video on this that if i
define some state variable
let's just say
heat content
let's say i wanted to find some state
variable heat content and i would say
that the
change in
change in heat content would of course
be equal to the change in heat and
that's what i'm defining if i'm adding
heat to the system my heat content
should go up but the problem with that
heat content state variable was that
let's say over here
i say that the heat content
let's say that the heat content is equal
to five now i just showed you that if we
go on on some path here and we come back
and there's some area in this in in this
little path that i took that some heat
was added so let's say that this area
and you know let's say that this area
right here so this is q is equal to the
work done by the system let's say it's
equal to 2.
so every time if i started heat content
is equal to 5 that's just an arbitrary
number and i were to do this entire path
when i go back the heat content would
have to be seven and then when i go back
and do it again my heat content would
have to be nine it would have to
increment by two every time i do this
exact path it would have to increment by
the amount of area that this path goes
around so heat content can't be a state
variable because it's dependent on how
you got there a state verbal and
remember this in order to be a state
variable if you're at this point you
have to have the same value if your
internal energy was 10 here when you do
the path and you come back your internal
energy will be 10 again that's why
internal energy is a valid state
variable it's dependent only on your
state if your entropy was 50 here when
you go back and you do all sorts of
crazy things and you come back to this
point your entropy is once again 50. if
your pressure here is i don't know if
it's five atmospheres when you come back
here your pressure will be five
atmospheres your state verbal cannot
change based on what path you took if
you're at a certain state that's all
that matters to the state variable now
this heat content didn't work
and that's why we actually led into some
videos where i divided by t and we got
entropy which is was an interesting
variation but that's still not
satisfying what if we really wanted to
develop something that could in some way
be a state variable but at the same time
measure heat so obviously we're going to
have to make some compromises because if
we just do a very arbitrary kind of heat
content variable then every time you go
around this it's going to change so it's
not a
a valid state variable so let's see if
we can make up one
so let's just make up a definition let's
call my new thing that i'm going to try
to maybe approximate heat let's call it
h and just as a little bit of a preview
we're going to call it enthalpy
enthalpy
and let's just define it i'm just
playing around let's just define it as
the internal energy
plus
my pressure times my volume
plus pressure
times volume
so then what would my change would be my
change in enthalpy be
so my change in enthalpy will be of
course the change of these things but i
could just say that's my change in my
internal energy plus
my change in pressure
times volume
now this is interesting and i want to
make a point here this by definition is
a valid state variable why is it because
it's the combat is the addition of other
state variables
right at any point in my pv diagram and
it's also true if i did diagrams that
were entropy and temperature or anything
that dealt with state variables at any
point on my diagram
u is going to be the same no matter how
i got there p is by definition going to
be the same that's why it's at that
point v is definitely going to be the
same point so if i just add them up this
is a valid state variable because it's
just the sum of a bunch of other valid
state variables so let's see if we can
somehow relate this thing that we've
already established as a valid state
variable from the get go from our
definition this works
because it's just a sum of completely
valid state variables so let's see if we
can relate this somehow to heat so we
know what delta u is is from from one of
you know it's a it's if we're if we're
dealing with all of the internal energy
or the change internal energy and i'm
not going to deal with all the other
chemical potentials and all of that it's
equal to the heat applied to the system
heat applied to the system
minus the work done by the system right
and let me put everything else there the
change in
enthalpy is equal to the heat applied
minus the work done that's just the
change in internal energy
and plus delta pv this is just from the
definition of my enthalpy
now this is starting to look interesting
what's the work what's the work done by
a system what's the work done by system
so i could write change in h or enthalpy
is equal to the heat
applied to the system
minus
what's the work done by a system if i
have a
if i have some system here it's got some
piston on it you know if we're doing a
quasi static i have those the classic
pebbles that i've talked about in
multiple videos
when i apply heat or
when i let's say i remove some of these
pebbles so i
i'm at a different equilibrium but
what's actually happening when is the
work being done you have some pressure
being applied up here and this piston is
going to be moving up and your volume is
going to increase and we showed multiple
videos ago that the work done by the
system can be and you can kind of view
this as the volume expansion work it's
equal to
pressure
if we're pressure times change in volume
times change in volume and then let's
add the other part so this was our
change in internal energy i had several
videos where i show this
and let me add the other part of the
equation so our enthalpy our change in
enthalpy can be defined by this
now something interesting is going on
i said that i wanted to define something
because i wanted to somehow measure heat
content
my change in enthalpy
will be equal to the heat added to the
system if these last two terms cancel
out
if these if i can somehow get these last
two terms to cancel out then my change
in enthalpy will be equal to this if
somehow these are equal to each other so
under what conditions under what
conditions are these equal to each other
or another way under what conditions is
delta
pressure times volume equal to
pressure times delta volume when does
this happen when can i make the state
because if i can make the statement then
these two terms are equivalent right
here and then my change in enthalpy will
be equal to the heat added
well the only way i can make this
statement is if pressure is constant
if pressure is constant
constant
pressure
now why is that let's just think about
it mathematically if this is a constant
then if i just change
you know if this is just 5 5 times the
change in something is the same thing as
a change in five times that thing so it
just mathematically works out you can
work you could or if you if you view it
another way if this is a constant
if this is a constant you can just
factor it out
right i mean you could just say you know
well if i said the change in
5 x
that would be you know you could say
that's the that's equal to 5 times x
final
minus 5 times x initial
and you could say well that's just equal
to 5 times x final minus x initial
well that's just equal to 5 times the
change in x it's kind of almost too
obvious for me to explain i think this
you know sometimes when you over explain
things it might become more confusing so
this applies and the the five i'm just
doing is the analogy for a constant so
if pressure is constant then this
equation is true
so if pressure is constant if pressure
is constant so this is a key assumption
so if we have if if heat is being
applied in a constant pressure system so
we could write it this way
so i'll write it multiple times because
this is key
if pressure is constant
pressure is
constant then our definition our our our
little thing we made up this enthalpy
thing which we defined as internal
energy
internal energy plus pressure and volume
then in a constant pressure system our
change in enthalpy we just showed will
be equal to
is equal to the heat added to the system
because all of these two things become
equivalent under constant pressure so i
should write that this is only true when
heat is added in a constant pressure
system so how does this gel with what we
did up here on our pv diagram what's
happening in a constant pressure system
let me draw our pv diagram
that's p
that's v
let me make sure i'm right there this is
p
and this is v so what's happening in
constant pressure we're at some pressure
right there so if we're under constant
pressure that means we can only move
along this line
so we could go from here to there and
back to there or we could go from there
to there back to there so we could go
there all the way there and then go back
but what do we see about this is there
any area in this curve i mean there is
no curve to speak of because we're
staying at a constant pressure we've
kind of squeezed out this diagram we've
made the forward paths and the return
paths the same exact path so because of
this
because of this you don't have that
state problem right because no
no net heat is being added to the system
when you go from this point
all the way to this point and then back
to this point so because of that you can
kind of see visually that enthalpy in a
constant pressure when you're not moving
up and down in pressure is the same
thing as heat added so you might say hey
sal this was a bit of a compromise
constant pressure you know that's a big
assumption to make why is this useful at
all
well it's useful because most chemical
reactions especially ones that occur in
an open beaker or that might occur at
sea level and that should be a big clue
they occur at constant pressure you know
if i just have if i'm sitting at the
beach and i'm have my chemistry set and
i have some beaker of something and you
know and i'm throwing other stuff into
it and you know i'm looking for a
reaction or something it's a constant
pressure system this is going to be
atmospheric pressure one atmosphere i'm
sitting at sea level so this is actually
very useful for this is a very useful
concept for
everyday chemical experience it might
not be so useful for engines because
engines always have pressure changing
but it's very useful for actual
chemistry for actually dealing with you
know what what's going to happen to a
reaction at at a constant pressure so
what we're going to see is that this
enthalpy you can kind of view it as the
heat content when pressure is constant
in fact it is the heat content when
pressure is constant so somehow we were
well not somehow i showed you how
we were able to make this definition
which by definition was a state variable
because it was the sum of other state
variables and if we just make that one
assumption of constant pressure it all
of a sudden
reduces to the heat content of that
system so we'll talk more in the future
of of of measuring enthalpy but you just
have to say if it's pressure is constant
enthalpy is the same thing as it's
really only useful when we're dealing
with constant pressure but if we have
pressure constant enthalpy can be
imagined as heat content and it's very
useful for understanding whether
chemical reactions need heat to occur or
whether they release heat so on and so
forth see you soon